now gavin newsom california democrats
they are in an all-out full-on panic
ahead of the september 14th recall race
polls now showing a race neck and neck
on whether to recall the failed far left
governor
now just look at this disgusting
headline from the la times larry elder
is the black face of white supremacy
you've been warned
the la times printed that
here to react he's leading in the polls
in terms of
uh who would replace
gavin newsom if question one he is
recalled i see you smiling we've been
friends a long time i am sorry i am a
genuinely friend to friends sorry that
you have to go through something
as evil and horrific and racist as that
well sean thank you for that but i
anticipated that that would happen this
is why a lot of people don't go into
into politics because of the politics of
personal destruction this is not the
first time the la times has attacked me
there's another writer who all but
called me a black david duke and i've
been a politician now for a little more
than a month and at first as you know
they tried to keep me off the ballot by
claiming i didn't properly turn over
five years of taxes we ended up suing
and a left-wing judge said that elder
was right and threw that out and put me
right back on the on the ballot and then
i was accused of hating women because i
wrote an article 21 years ago where i
cited a study from the left-wing
annenberg school of journalism that
looked at 25 questions i asked of men
and women and men knew more about those
questions than did women and i quoted a
left-wing professor who said the reason
women knew less is because they get
their primary source from local news
quote and she said local watching local
news makes you dumber close quote i
didn't say that she did then i was
accused of brandishing a firearm and a
former girlfriend i want to say right
now i've never brandished a firing
firearm loaded or unloaded at anybody as
for the rest of the allegations she made
i'm not going to dignify them by giving
them a comment and now we have this
article from the la times you're right
sean they are scared to death they know
that if california can elect a
conservative governor like myself and
they can and they will on september the
14th that any state can and they're
deathly afraid of this i'm told that
senator dianne feinstein is more feeble
than joe biden and if she retires or
become incapacitated they're afraid that
i will appoint a republican governor and
that would shift the whole balance in
the senate so for all those reasons it's
mayday for the democrats and so joe
biden has weighed in conley harris has
weighed in
elizabeth warren's cut a commercial
didn't defend his record on crime on
homelessness on the rising cost of
living on the way he shut down this
state without paying attention to
science they just attacked attacked the
tech and said it was driven by
republicans that's all they've got
and then there's rolling blackouts
brownouts water shortages paying for
water
the covet hypocrisy and i guess gavin
newsom
has a very different view of what
foreign policy should be as he praised
joe biden this week which i'm sure you
took note of
oh i sure did he said that he's proud of
what joe biden did in afghanistan it's
it's a window into gavin newsom's
incompetence and you didn't mention the
employment development department where
he allowed 30 billion dollars to go that
should have gone for unemployment
benefits for people in california to go
to criminals inside the country and
international criminals the man is
completely incompetent and that's why
nearly 1.7 million people signed a
petition maybe a third of them were
independents and democrats who just
voted for him two years earlier and
that's why i'm asking people to go to
elder.com because he can and will raise
an unlimited amount of money already
he's raised about 50 million dollars
primarily from the teachers union
they're afraid of me because i support
school choice uh the public sector
unions hollywood and big tech
yeah they're going to throw a lot of
money at you
i i
this just crosses
so many lines and such a double standard
among the uh you know woke
uh
you ca
snowflakes out there apparently you can
say anything about an african-american
and it's fine even in the l.a times it's
it's disgusting nobody should have to go
through that in this day and age period
end of sentence larry thank you i'm
sorry hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else